we are at CES 2016 with PDP to check out
a new product the xbox one supercharger
add-on for the controller that sounds
crazy because it can recharge a
controller in 60 seconds or less but
it's not what you might think it doesn't
use a battery uses something different
i'm here with jake from PDP can you
explain in general terms how this is
different from a traditional battery and
essentially what benefits that offers a
consumer yeah it's a so it is what we
call a power pack it's still a power
source just like a battery is but it
does not have a chemical reaction like a
battery does so what you have inside of
a battery is typically a core that is
causing a reaction allowing the charge
to build providing so many milliamp
hours for whatever it is you're using
this is something different I can't get
into too much detail of what it is we've
got a patent pending on it though so
what happens is you take you set the
controller down into the dock on the PDP
supercharger here let it run for 60
seconds less than the time it takes to
boil a pot of water go outside stretch
your arms go to the bathroom yeah enjoy
the rest of the day maybe see the Sun
for the first time and by the time you
come back in 60 seconds later you have
one hundred percent allowing another
eight to 12 hours of gameplay it
honestly sounds like too good to be true
but obviously you guys wouldn't be here
if it didn't work I know you don't have
it any idea about pricing or release
state at this point but is it safe to
say sometime in 2016 people will be able
to get their hands on this I'm really
hoping so I mean we like I said we don't
have dates we don't have pricing they're
like you were saying but we're open for
this year so fingers crossed it's going
to be out there it is real we have it we
have it in our offices so we've tested
it it runs another eight to 12 so it's
pretty comparable then to the standard
battery pack in the expo i guess the
batteries he would put into an xbox one
controller pretty much on par yeah so
you're not losing any time but you are
gaining a lot because well you're doing
something completely different and
you're gaining all that time back
instead of having your controller sit
down on the dock tapping your fingers 60
seconds that's a lot of fallout you know
one thing with wireless better i guess
not wireless batteries but you know like
batteries tend to sort of they lose
their ability to hold charges over time
and they have like diminishing returns
is that something that will people will
have to deal with with this technology
or is it in your opinion may be better
or even worse I don't know that then the
battery technology like lithium ion and
such since that is a chemical reaction
the chemical half life starts to break
down we're not going to be having that
issue here but there will still be you
know if it's if it's off if it's off the
cradle it will start to lose lose lose
charge so you are going to have to
recharge but again 60 seconds is 60
seconds so you're not going to have that
half life of well a year later it's
going to work for two minutes so that
won't be a concern we're really just
hoping that we can keep this going and
maybe even bring this to other things
this looks really awesome I can't wait
to hear more about it thank you for
showing it to me Jake for more
controllers and gave me stuff in general
stay tuned gamespot at CES 2016
you